it's football's biggest kept secret it's
a cycle of
toxic masculinity because as an adult
once you've been through it you want to
bury it as much as you can
for years after he was released from
fulham academy max couldn't bear to
watch
football his body was so wrecked a kick
about with friends was a distant dream
he had been among the country's most
talented young players
as a youth international for wales he
starred alongside gareth bale and aaron
ramsey
max noble one of the english-born
players in the side
for the thousands of boys who don't make
it those
sold a dream and cast adrift with little
regard for what happens next
it is he says a form of child abuse
there's no aftercare for young boys that
have given and dedicated their whole
lives
so sometimes one football club maybe a
couple of football clubs but essentially
academy systems
and for you to then feel like a failure
after is what
why we see boys committing suicide now
why we see boys self-harming i've got
two friends that tried to kill
themselves i've got another two
that actually hung themselves these are
boys who went to
football academies yeah different clubs
i think just three different clubs in
south london
so it's a massive a massive issue in
football
max was signed by fulham aged 15
encouraged by the club to quit school
before taking his gcses
by 19 he'd been released requiring
double knee surgery
which he believes was caused by medical
treatment at the club
at 16 i'm getting injections in my knees
at 16 years old
getting painkillers given to me daily
i've got stories of my friends who would
go out with four or five strappings on
their legs just to train
how many injections you had in your
knees so many so many
i mean 10 15 over the course of a couple
of years
max also says he experienced racism at
the club
we were told that we had bad attitudes
which i think is another massive issue
in football is that how all young black
boys are labeled with bad attitudes
um so there was seven or eight black
boys in the team
we're all from different parts of london
all from different backgrounds
completely different families
and we were told that because we've got
bad attitudes and we don't listen and we
don't want to learn
that we can't eat in the canteen so we
can't eat the food in the canteen we
have to eat in the changing room
so they gave us sandwiches afterwards
shower in a dirty chain room they put
the sandwiches on a tray on the floor
in a statement fulham football club said
we condemn bullying racism and
discrimination in any form
and work hard to ensure they have no
place here the club is investigating and
today has found nothing to support the
historic claims
the club will liaise with all relevant
parties as the process continues
max is now campaigning for a change in
the law to make it obligatory for clubs
to look after young players who are
released
heartbroken with no qualifications and
no idea what to do next
those he says are football's forgotten
boys and they're everywhere
martha kellner sky news